a master
for the story
this time will not be swapped
none of the six played
because i think on tommy 10
here i wanted to go to the 15 i have that
now is also an
idea how we swapped
paths no
yes i know it says a
little better here
I don't really know how much
with the advantage
so I'm trying to relieve myself here now by
more exchanges
what's coming because now on 10
635 didn't count believe
then should be okay
there have wings is a bit a
bit bad but
cover here
I actually only have that 96 as a
potential weakness
springer her sex
but a very good field
jessica me usable or
yes even the 5 is ok now
actually
at least he is ok
let's just play
like that he now has a jersey of her
great trick she used to
call it still
now hit a bit as if doing
well mistake the seven could
threaten one day so the
what would
the three do
jumper fix
is then somehow a danger so th
t the three here I still have 5 mysel
stupid what threaten oh ye
h that makes it okay then that
as but that was that
allowed it that a lit
le uncomfortable he could play the endgame with
he specified pawns then yes
i don't do much
i hope the
timing
human blood will be played
that you stand there in your soup
at least king still reasonably active
that you can give them up somehow
cheaply here
that doesn't help i can't
stand around forever
trying to always get you
against the odds
so bad
chem chem
check
just one word to say [ __ ] yeah that
different is somehow no
longer appropriate now
otherwise I won't say anything more